it's a bit like saying a simulated
hurricane doesn't make anybody wet well
simulated persons inside that simulation
would get wet but no you won't you're
using the same word wet yeah well it
should be to simulation right but to
mean something that is not even
comparable it's something totally
different
[Music]
so I'm rather fond of David Chalmers
take on virtual reality he's been
cornering the market of philosopher
materiality ever since he wrote about
Matrix and the philosophy and he makes
this argument that we should actually
treat Virtual Worlds as real in the
sense that virtual objects have causal
Powers if I use my virtual sword on the
virtual Dragon I might be able to kill
it the virtual Dragon might threaten my
virtual Avatar there are interactions
going on in this little environment it's
in some sense a closed system where
cause and effect works according to
their own little rules and as he points
out this means that experience is in
their matter so David Chalmers Who full
disclosure I think is actually being
wrong on pretty much everything he's
doing in his life
um just to put things out there has a
very interesting
conception of causality as you pointed
out the difference between
my virtual dragon and a real dragon
coming into this room is I if I'm afraid
of the virtual Dragon I can just turn
off my computer and the virtual dragon
is gone the real one is gonna eat me no
matter what uh and there's nothing I can
I can turn off Philip K dick who was a
famously dystopian brilliant science
fiction uh author said that reality is
the thing that doesn't go away when you
stop believing in it right and that is
the part of the problem one of one of
the points that was made a few minutes
ago was that there has to be
consequences
for for something to be called a reality
well I think there are consequences
because quite a lot of interaction we do
in Virtual Reality might have the
resistant effects not just in the sense
that maybe when you turn on the computer
the dragon is uh back there and
programmed to be even more angry but a
lot of interaction we do in Virtual
Reality or social if I yell at somebody
in an online Forum there are actual
consequences now you might say yeah but
that's because we're real people behind
the the scenes here you get really upset
but I think the virtual reality we could
be universities just like that the
university is a place where people come
together and role play this we are the
activity we have a various names and
ideas about what's going on we're very
happen to be very physically but we're
playing a kind of elaborate social game
according to particular social rules and
many of them matter quite a lot for the
rewards we get in terms of payment and
or credibility to getting invited one
wonderful festivals things like that
so I do think that actually that when
the Lobster Thermidor is not real that
mostly matters if you care about the
nourishment part but if you say eating a
lobster thermador is a social occasion
and I want to have a nice Lobster with
my friends even though over this route
of many continents that aspect of a nice
dinner is relevant talking about back to
Chalmers right one of the classic
arguments against the Chalmers notion of
uh computer uploading and and virtual
realities and all that sort of stuff is
that or is his view of Consciousness is
that uh yeah you can simulate uh
physical processes in a lot of detail
for instance you can simulate
photosynthesis bit by bit even at the
quantum level and the only thing you
don't get out of a simulated
photosynthesis is sugar which is the
only thing that matters yeah right and
without sugar pushing back against this
to say you get simulated sugar which is
real within that simulator it's a bit
like saying simulated hurricane doesn't
make anybody wet well simulated persons
inside that simulation would get wet but
no they won't you're you're you're
you're using I mean the interesting
thing to me is uh I understand what
you're saying but no you won't you're
using the same word wet yeah well it
should be to simulated right but to mean
something then it's not even comparable
it's something totally different
simulated wetness has nothing to do with
actual Wellness but but the problem is
of course we're already living in a
simulated world this world the classic
environment us is made out of weird
quantum mechanics stuff but we're not
observing that we're see living in the
classical war world to us there is
wetness but there is actually just wave
functions moving in the Hilbert Space
level description yes I mean just
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas